well I did something that nobody thought
was possible I get rid of Roe v Wade and
by doing that
it put pro-lifers in a very strong
negotiating position now they're
negotiating different things and you
know I happen to be of the Ronald Reagan
School in terms of uh exemptions where
you have the life of the mother rape and
Princess mother's life so you have that
and I think you know for me that's
something that works very well and for
probably 80 85 percent because don't
forget we do have to win elections but I
did something that nobody could do and I
also made them the radicals because they
are willing and able to kill babies in
the ninth month they're willing to kill
babies that's radical pro-life isn't
radical okay so this is crazy stuff of
course it's all untrue but I if I were
Trump I don't know that I'd be bragging
about ending Roe v Wade given the
unpopularity of that decision